let's talk about Oprah now because she
is sounding the alarm on this kovat 19
crisis and how it hits way too close to
home hey y'all this coronavirus shaking
up the world Oprah who had pneumonia
back in August told GMA it was her own
health scare that led her to quarantine
away from Stedman Graham even in my own
family Stedman was running around still
speaking in st. Louis had speaking
engagements I was like you need to
cancel that segment you need to cancel
and he was like well I'm not gonna
cancel I'm not gonna cancel it they're
not gonna cancel I go you need to cancel
and so it ends up he didn't cancel and
then when it was time to come home
you can't come in the house you can't he
just didn't believe and I think seven
did relieved nor did a lot of other
people believe well you can't shut the
whole country down oh yeah you can oh
yeah you can and yes we have our first
dinner together in two weeks I think
this is just the beginning we're not
gonna get back to normal we're gonna get
back to a new normal
meanwhile Oprah's bestie Gail just spoke
to Rita Wilson for CBS this morning her
first interview since she and Tom Hanks
tested positive for coronavirus I was
very tired I felt extremely achy
uncomfortable didn't want to be touched
and then the fever started why did Rita
think okay now is the time for me to sit
down and talk about my diagnosis and
Tom's diagnosed Larissa and she thought
if this will help someone else
understand what we went through right
and how we came out on the other side I
think that's ultimately why she decided
to do it did Tom have similar symptoms
to you were your symptoms different he
had milder symptoms he didn't have as
high a fever by the way did you know she
correct I live in that the hip hop this
is hip hop up today I give props to hip
hop so hip hop hooray
during Rita's time in quarantine she
posted this video rapping Naughty by
nature's hip hop hooray
she did a remix with a group to raise
money for Kovan research yeah she got
street cred with that when everybody was
like Rita's got bars what's happening
Rita Wilson's got street cred
[Music]